El objetivo de este video es ayudarnos a
visualizar lo que sucede en una solución
a un nivel microscópico, bueno, realmente a
un nivel molecular; además de practicar el
dibujo de este tipo de esquemas, porque podrían
pedirte que lo realices dependiendo de la clase
de Química en la que estés. Lo que tenemos aquí
son tres soluciones acuosas diferentes, lo que
significa que el soluto está disuelto en agua. El
primero es cloruro de sodio, después tenemos el
cloruro de magnesio y por acá tenemos C₁₂H₂₂O₁₁
que en otras palabras es sacarosa, y cada uno
de ellos está disuelto en agua. Ahora bien, lo
que vamos a hacer es intentar dibujar lo que
está sucediendo a nivel de las partículas en los
respectivos rectángulos. Así que, en primer lugar,
pensemos qué ocurre con el cloruro de sodio. Lo
primero de lo que podemos darnos cuenta es que
el cloruro de sodio es un compuesto iónico, está
hecho de 1 ion de sodio cargado positivamente, o
un catión, y 1 ion de cloro cargado negativamente.
Ahora bien, van a estar en una razón 1 a 1:
por cada sodio hay un cloro, y si queremos
dibujarlos también podemos pensar en sus tamaños
relativos. Para eso traigamos la tabla periódica
de los elementos. Podemos ver aquí que ambos están
en el tercer periodo, y si sólo comparamos
un átomo de sodio contra un átomo de cloro,
la tendencia general es que a medida que avanzamos
más a la derecha y tengamos más electrones en
la capa exterior, el radio tiende a hacerse más
pequeño, entonces el átomo de cloro es más pequeño
que el átomo de sodio. Pero no estamos hablando de
átomos, estamos hablando de iones, entonces el ion
de sodio parcialmente positivo perdió 1 electrón,
es decir, tiene la configuración electrónica del
neón; mientras que el anión de cloro tiene la
configuración electrónica del argón. Entonces,
en realidad resulta que el anión de cloro será más
grande que el catión de sodio. Lo que haremos será
representar el anión de cloro de esta forma, le
pondremos una carga negativa, y el catión de sodio
lo representaremos un poco más pequeño, algo así.
Para visualizarlo por cada ion de sodio cargado
positivamente tenemos que dibujar también un anión
de cloro: aquí hay uno de ellos y otro. Muy bien,
ese es el soluto. Algunas veces sólo te pedirán
que dibujes el soluto, en cuyo caso ya habrás
acabado, pero puedes preguntarte ¿cómo es que
interactúa con el agua? Y este ejemplo nos ayudará
a entender lo que sucede. ¿Por qué el cloruro de
sodio, en general, por qué los compuestos iónicos
se disuelven bien en agua? Bueno, dibujemos las
moléculas de agua, y si todavía queremos mantener
el tamaño relativo correcto podemos regresar a
nuestra tabla periódica de los elementos. Sabemos
que el catión de sodio tiene la configuración
electrónica del neón, y el oxígeno es muy cercano
a eso. Y cuando hablamos del agua los átomos
de oxígeno acapararán los electrones. Recuerda:
los electrones pasan un poco más de tiempo
alrededor del oxígeno que del hidrógeno,
así que tendrán tamaños parecidos el oxígeno, el
agua y el catión de sodio. Obviamente estos no
serán dibujos exactos, pero podemos imaginar que
cada molécula de agua se va a ver así: tenemos 1
oxígeno con 2 hidrógenos. Ahora, la pregunta será
¿cuál será su orientación? Y es muy importante que
sea la correcta, especialmente cuando trabajamos
con agua, ya que es una molécula polar. Bueno,
como sabemos que los electrones pasan más tiempo
alrededor del oxígeno -y esto lo hemos comentado
en muchos videos-, la parte del oxígeno tiene una
carga parcial negativa, mientras que la parte de
los hidrógenos tiene una carga parcial positiva,
entonces la molécula de agua se orientará de
manera que la parte parcialmente negativa del
oxígeno atraerá a los iones positivos y las partes
parcialmente positivas del hidrógeno atraerán
a los iones negativos. Por lo tanto tendremos
algo así: este es el oxígeno y estos son los 2
hidrógenos, tenemos 1 oxígeno y 2 hidrógenos,
ya que esta parte de la molécula del agua tiene
una carga parcialmente positiva y atraerá a este
anión de cloro. Una vez más tendremos 2 hidrógenos
y 1 oxígeno por acá; la parte del oxígeno atraerá
al sodio cargado positivamente, es decir, a los
cationes de sodio. Y podríamos llenar todo el
esquema, pero creo que ya tienes la idea de cómo
se ve el agua y cómo está orientada. Ahora bien,
para los siguientes, enfoquémonos sólo en los
solutos. ¿Cómo se verá el soluto de esta segunda
solución? Bueno una vez más el cloruro de magnesio
es un compuesto iónico, por lo que se disociará en
sus iones constituyentes, por cada ion de magnesio
que, de hecho tendrá una carga de +2, tendremos
2 iones de cloro cargados negativamente, aniones.
¿Y cuál es su tamaño relativo? Para ayudarnos con
esto, regresemos a la tabla periódica. Si estamos
hablando del ion de magnesio cargado positivamente
con +2, tendrá la configuración electrónica del
neón y tendrá más protones que el ion de sodio,
así que va a tirar aún más fuerte de ellos,
será incluso más pequeño que el ion de sodio.
Entonces podemos dibujar los iones de magnesio
de esta forma, un poco más pequeño que el sodio,
y escribiremos +2 porque tiene una carga positiva
de +2, por acá pondremos otro con su +2 porque
tiene una carga positiva, y por cada uno de éstos
tendremos 2 aniones de cloro, uno aquí, tal vez
otro por acá, uno acá y tal vez otro por acá. Y
si te piden que dibujes el solvente, es decir,
el agua, entonces debes orientarla de manera
similar, donde la parte parcialmente positiva
de los hidrógenos atraigan a los iones negativos
de cloro y el oxígeno de la molécula del agua
atraiga a estos iones de magnesio con carga de
+2. Bien, ahora, ¿qué hay de la sacarosa? Bueno,
no es un compuesto iónico, así que en esta
situación no se disociará. Una molécula de
sacarosa es relativamente grande, así que vamos
a dibujarlo así y tal vez por acá tengamos otra.
Y la razón por la que se disuelve bien en agua
es que hay partes en una molécula de sacarosa
que tienen una polaridad, tiene muchos grupos OH,
entonces hay partes de la molécula que tienen una
carga parcialmente positiva y otras partes de la
molécula que tienen cargas parcialmente negativas,
otras partes tienen carga parcialmente positiva
y con esto es capaz de atraer a las diferentes
partes de la molécula del agua, dependiendo si es
la parte parcialmente positiva o negativa. Así que
vamos a escribirlas así: C₁₂H₂₂O₁₁, C₁₂H₂₂O₁₁.
Y por cuestiones de tiempo no vamos a dibujar
las moléculas de agua aquí, pero para dibujarlas
inteligentemente tendrías que saber qué partes de
esta molécula más grande tienen una carga parcial
positiva o negativa. Pero como podemos ver,
el hecho de que se pueda disociar en iones que
claramente tienen carga o que sea una molécula
cuyas partes tienen una carga parcial,
es decir, una carga asociada a ellas,
es lo que les permite disolverse bien
en un solvente polar como lo es el agua.